and joining us now for the latest
medical perspective on the outbreak is
CBS News medical contributor dr. David
agus he joins us from Los Angeles David
almost half the country right now is
under this stay-at-home order where are
we in the effort to flatten the curve
well you know there's a 2:00 to 9:00
date incubation period for this virus
and then the virus period is about 10 to
14 days so when you make an intervention
like we're doing with keeping home we
won't see that impact on the numbers so
probably the end of next week hopefully
it'll start to flatten and then the week
after hopefully we'll start to see a
decline over those next two weeks so I'm
praying that all the action all of us
are doing stepping up which is really
amazing is going to have an impact on
those numbers but they're still going up
at the present time the president had
suggested possibly getting the country
out of this stay at home state around
Easter is that realistic the way I look
at things is we have to look at the data
the data will decide when we get out of
this day at home state the virus and the
data are driving here we are now trying
to switch to offense so that we can be
in charge so I have no idea what date is
going to be I certainly hope that it's
in you know the next month I can't
predict what they I don't think anybody
can I think putting a stake in the stand
saying I hope it's this date is fine but
the data will really decide where we are
but David different areas will flatten
at different times right no question
about it is that certain cities I mean
right now in New York is the epicenter
of the United States where this virus is
and it's going to in transition to other
cities other cities are having dramatic
impact with stay at home and being more
compliant with it and we're gonna see
flattening of the curve there and I
think it's gonna vary region by region
and the more we restrict travel from
region to region we're gonna get better
results unfortunately we're in an
unprecedented time where we have to sit
in one place and not spread the virus at
all when there's a group of kids on a
beach somewhere and then they go around
the country that keeps the virus going
we all have to step up the b1 in this
where it's not going to work David we've
talked so much about the healthcare
workers who are on the front line
of this war against Corona and the
incredible work they're doing every
single day without many times the proper
resources and equipment what can we do
as individual Americans right now to
support them well the devastating
numbers you just showed of 10% of cases
in Italy or health care workers is just
unimaginable you know you see hotels in
New York like the Four Seasons stepped
up and said hey health care workers we
know many of you can't go home because
you're afraid to infect your spouse your
children your neighbors so we're gonna
give you places to stay I hope
restaurants step up and and feed them
and we do that in every city you know
these are heroes who are putting their
lives at stake and they don't want to
endanger their families so they're
sleeping in their cars we have to step
up and take care of them by any resource
we can get them the personal protective
gear and give them places to stay and
food to eat so they can care for us you
know David it's interesting if you talk
to people out there to some of the
people that never would have expected to
be in this somebody who's working as a
grocery clerk that's that's really
interacting with the public they're ones
that also feel like they're on the front
line that's raising anxiety people are
taking care of others at home there's a
lot of stress going on right now is
there any advice to people on how to
deal with the anxiety they may never
have experienced before it is an amazing
thing where a grocery clerk a
maintenance person and a doctor are the
heroes you know the one thing I can tell
you is or two things actually is eat
three meals a day nothing in between
don't graze we're all at home you're
tempting to just grab something all
during the day what you want is your
hormones to go up down up down during
the day so nothing in between meals and
then walk your lymphatics that control
your immune system have no muscles so in
their walls actually the rhythmic
contraction of your body of your legs
walking and your muscles working make
your body works you just walk even if
it's a small apartment walk in circles
walk walk walk without getting too far
ahead of anything here David dr. Falchi
was talking about how the virus then
would potentially come back at a later
date can you talk more about that and
and long term planning right now as we
deal with this short term crisis
so viruses come in ways we enact rather
draconian means we stop the virus from
spreading and it goes away and then in
another area where it becomes winter in
the globe it can start and then spread
again around the globe if the virus does
come back though we're gonna have
medications ready we're gonna have our
healthcare infrastructure ready to take
it on we're working on a vaccine
hopefully in the next 12 to 18 months so
we're going to be much more prepared
than we are today
in addition which is key is we're
developing a test we're a prick of the
finger will tell you whether you have
immunity to this virus or not and so
going forward our frontline workers will
be people who have immunity so they
can't get it and they can't spread it
and that's a data-driven way where we
can really keep this virus in check and
take care of people who haven't yet been
exposed to the virus David very quickly
a lot of conversation among my friends
people wondering is it possible that
some of us had this back in January and
just didn't know oh yes probably many of
you did although I'm not sure who you
hang around with that but there's no
question many of us had mild symptoms we
didn't know what it was we didn't want
to call our doctor with everything going
on to stress him or her or week although
the doctor said stay at home and
self-quarantine yourself this blood test
that looks at your immunity it looks at
the proteins your body called antibodies
that fought it say are they there
and it's a very simple inexpensive test
akin to a pregnancy test this should be
out I hope and pray over the next
several days it's been out in certain
towns in Colorado where they're testing
entire towns and saying who's been
exposed or not my hope is this is scaled
across the country so we can actually
have real data and all of us know if
you've been exposed you can actually go
out and you can work as a grocery clerk
and not worry about getting sick or
deliver food to somebody or work in an
emergency room that is huge talking
insist doctors nurses when that antibody
test is ready it's gonna be very
important dr. David agus thank you once
again